a battle over media rights and freedom
of speech
in india is coming to a boil messaging
provider whatsapp has filed a lawsuit
against the indian government
new social media rules require platforms
to name a
legally accountable representative and
to release dissident users data
which the lawsuit claims is a violation
of privacy rights
the main battleground for the dispute is
the ongoing farmers protests in the
country
india's farmers are playing a key role
in the country's battle for freedom of
speech
they're protesting bitterly against the
government's new agricultural law
legislation they say will ruin their
livelihoods
the farmers have also been using social
media networks to mobilize their
supporters
something the government in delhi
doesn't like just as it dislikes the
social media criticism of its
coronavirus policies
delhi has demanded that u.s big tech
platforms like facebook and twitter
close down
certain accounts and delete some
articles and hashtags
there's a lot at stake for the big tech
giants
twitter has more than 70 million indian
users
facebook over 400 million and
facebook's subsidiary whatsapp boasts
over
half a billion subscribers more than in
any other country
their impressive revenue streams and the
conflict between the platforms and the
indian government over free speech on
the internet has
intensified in recent months it's
getting to the point where the companies
will have to decide just how much the
indian market is worth to them
let's take a closer look at the matter
with journalist nikhil
pava in delhi welcome to the program
nichol good to have you now these
rules these rules took effect today
what exactly is it that the government
is taking offense in here
well chris according to the rules um you
know if if social media platforms don't
take down content
after receiving orders within 36 hours
or if they don't
provide info to law enforcement agencies
based on their demands
within 72 hours uh or even if let's say
users file a complaint and and
and these platforms don't address the
grievances within 15 days
and remember whatsapp for example has
over 500 million internet users
um then they will basically lose their
safe harbor
they might be liable for the content and
this means that with
you know over with that many users and
that much content
uh platforms will not survive this
liability in india
so what in effect is happening is that
uh the indian government is trying to
control online speech
by imposing more control over tech
platforms
and uh these laws on them they are
applicable today
but in the past also such laws haven't
been
haven't been enforced so the government
tends to enforce the laws
arbitrarily or use them as a sort of
it uses them as as leverage to
intimidate the platforms
so this is not a good time to be a
platform in india
and that's probably why whatsapp has
gone to code in fact whatsapp situation
is
much worse they are expected to hand
over
the originator or the information about
an originator of a message
which will mean that they'll have to
re-architect that entire platform
globally which will compromise privacy
for users globally
and that's why they've gone to court the
demand from the indian government is
unrealistic
and you know it's really uh unbelievable
that
the indian government expected whatsapp
to re-architect their platform
within just three months of these
guidelines being issued
that's impossible i mean nico what
consequences are companies facing if
they don't adhere
to these rules well
someone's going to go to jail so they
are expected to hire a chief compliance
officer
who will have potentially criminal
liability
for any lawsuit so for example if two
people are
if one person suing another for criminal
defamation and india
does have criminal defamation laws then
the platform
could be liable for that and therefore
the chief compliance
officer that you know facebook or
twitter or youtube
might hire would also be liable for that
same content
and i don't think platforms can survive
that liability someone's going to go to
jail at some point in time
journalist nikhil pava in delhi thank
you for your thoughts